Where is it at?
- Right there!
- Hey.
Ay ya ya--
- Ooh, he's pretty.
A red snake.
Boy, that make a good hat band.
Say your prayers.
NARRATOR: A tried and true
tradition in the swamp
is looking good.
What you gonna
do with that skin?
That looks like-- you
don't want me to tell
you what that looks like.
[laughing]
NARRATOR: And for Shelby,
the swamp is a one-stop shop.
That's gonna be
a good one, man.
How's it look?
- Hey, that's pretty.
Look, you put it to
make 'em fit your head.
You wear 'em like
that till they dry.
I thought you was gonna drag
me out here for bull-bull-[bleep
but it ain't
turning out too bad.
NARRATOR: Now, the
swamp don't just
provide fashion accessories.
It's got everything you need
for the medicine cabinet too.
You see this?
It's a medici-mal mushroom.
It means medicine.
NARRATOR: But to get
the very best stuff--
[yelling]
NARRATOR: Sometimes you gotta
be crazy enough to go toe-to-toe
with slithering creatures.
And crazy is a swamp
man's specialty.
Some scientists in New Orleans
looking for some snake venom
to help people
when they get bit.
Oh!
I'mma catch some
snakes and sell 'em.
Get me some snake money.
What you got?
What is that?
- Some little pincers and a bag.
Oh, it's that thing
to pick up trash.
Yeah.
I'm not gonna touch them snakes.
SHELBY: I'll touch 'em.
NARRATOR: Now, Shelby
and his pal Doug
have been running the swamp
since they was itty-bitty.
- Man, I can't believe you.
- I can't wait, man.
I like catching [bleep] snakes.
- Do you?
Damn right, man.
Man.
NARRATOR: And they
know where they
can find a hissing pot of gold.
SHELBY: Hold on.
NARRATOR: If they can get there.
SHELBY: Are you all right?
DOUG: (LAUGHING) Yeah.
Just be careful and watch
them big cottonmouths.
DOUG: I'm a little worried
about this, Shelby.
You gonna be all right, man.
I told you.
If it's your time to
die, you gonna die.
Look, look, look!
We can get the money now!
Aw man!
- Watch him!
Watch him!
Did you feel him bite you?
I've been bit a hell
of a lot of times, man.
I'm damn near immune
to snake venom.
Look!
There, ha!
Here comes another one!
[laughing]
Got another one, Dougie.
[yelling]
- He got you, didn't he?
- Yeah.
It wasn't bad, though.
Bit the hair off my leg.
Don't be fooling
with no snakes--
especially kids.
'Cause they will kill
you, sometimes they
have to cut your fingers
off, cut your arm off.
Here we go!
Look, look, look, look.
I see a damn rattlesnake
in the damn grass.
That son of a bitch will bite
the [bleep] out of you, man.
He ain't got no venom
in him, but he'll
bite the piss out you.
DOUG: Watch him!
Watch him!
NARRATOR: Now, in the swamp
there's a traditional way
of taking care of a snake.
DOUG: What are you doing?
NARRATOR: And then-- well,
there's the Shelby way.
His head just come off.
That is crazy!
[laughing]
Never seen someone do that.
Damn snake-- look at it!
[gunshot]
Oh my.
NARRATOR: Now, Shelby don't
always go to such extremes.
There he is!
You got him.
We got him that time!
Look out!
Hey, hey, oh, whoa!
NARRATOR: Sometimes he uses
a lighter touch to keep
them snakes from a-biting him.
Get him off of me.
Snake bit son of a gun.
Gonna bring him home.
Let's eat it, man.
Come on, bring him with us.